foreign
welcome to the show
hi thanks for having me I I think I need
some tough love as I sit in my Tesla
um
there goes the tough love because Rachel
loves her
a Tesla I do love a Tesla yeah mine's
paid for okay very nice perfect so we
have to sell it we're doing good
so I do I think I have so many
complicated questions until I play over
what I think you guys are going to say
to me and and I know the answer so I was
debt free a millionaire with a property
that was you know had a lot of equity
and you know some money in the bank and
a good income and I was a single mom I
was widowed at 39. oh wow and
I I had a nice Nest Egg no debt I met a
fantastic man
um we got married a few years ago and
with this awesome guy that you know
adopted my daughter came a massive
amount of debt
um to the tune of close to a half a
million dollars and it was school loans
and some credit card and some high
interest uh short-term debt and I want
to know
um you know the nest egg that I had
built up was mine but it's ours
um the home equity we sold that house
bought a house that we could all live in
we still have a lot of equity in that
house
but am I paying off his school loan so
that we can be debt free we have two
paid for cars we have a lovely income I
just really have a hard time paying off
his past life yeah and I hear that and
and I
um you know I feel like it's easier for
us to kind of harp on the ones that just
got married and they're like oh it's his
debt my debt like you've just entered to
a marriage you know but when you've
lived two separate lives in a sense
right um because you got married later
had kids and it's like you're merging
these two lives I think it's a it's a
harder uh pill to swallow so I hear that
Catherine so don't say that this is I'm
not saying that it's just easy because I
do have my answer and it is kind of
black and white but I want you to hear
that
um it is hard like I I get that I
absolutely get that uh but here's here's
the benefit let me say that when couples
can come together in a sense that you
say okay this money that was mine now
I've been entered into a marriage and
that means I am becoming one with
someone else and in every area of my
life and there's a sacrifice to that
right you could put in money you could
put in time with that you can put in
maybe the way you want to raise kids how
you want to spend holidays I mean you
could insert anything into that and we
just find that couples that have a
sacrificial spirit in a sense to say hey
I'm laying everything down and together
we're going to build a life as one they
Thrive and not just financially because
financially I believe they do because
you can run a race so much faster when
both of you are on that same page but I
think it's even deeper than that
Catherine there's a there's a there's a
spiritual element there that when you
say everything that I have is yours
even this nest egg and as hard as hard
as it is to be like oh
when you become one with that person it
does something in your marriage there's
an intimacy and a richness there now
I'll I'll let Kim jump in a second but
my own my other asterisk though
Catherine is I really want to make sure
that he's done with this right if his
spirit is and his attitude is God was so
stupid I took out all those loans I wish
I didn't uh never doing it again we're
living debt free and it's this attitude
shift as well that you guys have the
same value system then I think it would
be easier to say yeah we're in this
together now
if he doesn't and he's still kind of
messing around with debt and it's a
value system of yours to live debt-free
then we have a marriage issue there of a
values issue does that make sense
Catherine
absolutely and and I I so connect with
what you said I think where I've played
this is you know I put our house on a
15-year mortgage we paid off both of our
cars and I have him putting all of his
income into his school loan payments
every month and I hit the house really
hard and I make sure everything else is
debt free I don't know that if I just
paid those off if that money that he has
every month that's going off those loans
would just disappear so I I don't know
that okay so I feel like we're on the
same page when we talk retirement but I
don't know if short term he would have
the intensity to get that loan debt off
and that money might just disappear
somewhere else okay that that's what I
was wondering because I could feel that
you were like I know what you're gonna
say and I know that there's something
that's really eating at you are you guys
I have two questions are you guys uh uh
shared you guys shared bank accounts you
guys doing all your money together you
guys separate bank accounts
um separate bank account yeah I I can I
could tell I pay all the bills I know so
it's but here's my point here's why I
asked the question that's what's eating
at you because you've got some natural
psychological tension and that's why
Dave and as an extension we for decades
have said we want you and Rachel just
gave you the whole Unity thing and so
you agreed with everything Rachel said
so if you agree with everything Rachel
said I know you did so you guys need to
combine bank accounts because that's
where the tension is coming from you're
like this is my money oh yeah I've
worked hard and then you're like I'm
having him put all of his income into
the student loan and so therein lies the
tension by which you called today so I I
listen first of all let me say
I completely understand why you feel the
way you feel I share Rachel's opinion on
I get it but you guys have decided to be
married and it's a long-term play yes or
no
yes yes so today
we combine bank accounts I still like
the strategy of taking all of his income
I love the intensity but I would not do
him on the student loans and you on the
house it's no we're going to put this in
the baby steps so we're going to put the
student loans in baby step two and
you've done this before and so both of
you attack the student loans and then
both of you pay off the house yeah and
Catherine hold on because Austin's gonna
pick up and we're going to give you a
year subscription to Ramsay plus and it
has every dollar in there which is our
budgeting app and I was just texting
with my husband this morning about a
horse because I was like what's this
venmo where should it Go and so I want
you guys to budget together for three
months okay and I want to say by
February there might be a more emotional
ease for you to pay everything pay it
all off together as a team once you guys
have been even from a tactical sense
budgeting together it's coming out of
one account like there is a Unity there
versus a separation like Ken was saying
so Catherine I hope that helps but stay
on the line Austin will pick up